joe rogan
is a dangerous dangerous racist
disinformation peddler he wasn't any of
those things a week ago but now the left
has decided he is all of those things
because he has positioned himself not
even with the conservatives just sort of
against the left-wing narrative joe
rogan is a liberal he's a full-on
liberal he's not a conservative but he's
contradicting some of the leftist
narratives and so now joe rogan's got to
go according to them
so the mob makes up its own narratives
facts be damned
first they tried to get him on covid
disinfo the problem is that joe rogan
has been more correct about kova than dr
fauci joe biden and rachelle wolenski
combined so they couldn't really get him
on that so what did they do they dug up
some old clips of his show in which he
was quoting people using the n-word and
they called him a racist they tried to
insis this is always what they do they
insinuated that he was a racist
and
unfortunately
joe has sort of kind of apologized
hello friends
um
i'm making this video to talk about the
most
regretful and shameful thing that i've
ever had to talk about publicly there's
a video that's out that's a compilation
of me saying the n-word
it's a video that's made of clips taken
out of context of me of 12 years of
conversations on my podcast and it's all
smushed together
and it looks horrible even to me now i
know that to most people there is no
context where a white person is ever
allowed to say that word never mind
publicly on a podcast and i agree with
that now
i haven't said it in years but for a
long time
when i would bring that word up like if
it would come up in conversation instead
instead of saying the n word i would
just say the word i thought as long as
it was in context people would
understand what i was doing like that
context was
part of the clip we were talking about
red fox how red fox said that word on
television in the 1970s and how times
have changed so much since then
so he's explaining why he did it the
explanation's perfectly fine but then
he's apologizing too and he's trying to
split this baby and he's trying to see
if he can put this cancel mob back into
pandora's box
i don't think
i don't think it's working i don't and i
think joe rogan's got to be very careful
here because this is going to have huge
effects not just for his show but but
actually this the joe rogan podcast the
way he behaves now is going to have huge
effects for free speech in america
joe rogan is apologizing for using the
n-word
the word he didn't say the it's
confusing because it's the only words
you're not allowed to say but he didn't
say the n word he said the end you know
the word the actual the n word okay when
he was quote he didn't say it in anger
he didn't say you
he was just quoting other people or
discussing the context of it and he did
this many times over the years and no
one ever had any problem with it until
the liberal establishment wanted to go
after joe rogan for having the audacity
to question the exalted dr fauci who has
been completely wrong about almost
everything with the coronavirus and so
because joe rogan now demonstrably has a
better record on covid than the head of
the national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases because of that now
they're digging up old clips out of
context and trying to insinuate that joe
rogan hates black people or something
like that and the problem is joe is sort
of apologizing
as a general rule
apologizing for out-of-context remarks
to people who have not been offended by
them and who do not care
is neither helpful nor good
it's not even the right thing to do
but it but beyond whether it's the right
thing to do or the wrong thing to do it
also won't help you i don't think it's
going to help people think it will help
them but it won't it'll actually hurt
them
i understand i have been the target of a
couple of cancel mobs in my life one of
which was pretty serious could have
taken down my career
and there were there were so many
incentives
to
just to apologize yes it was out of
context yes no one was really offended
yes they're just using this as a way to
attack you yes yes it's not whatever but
just just apologize and it'll all go
away it won't go away it won't that's
not it's not going to go back to normal
it's not going to you're not going to be
allowed to
just apologize and because it's not no
there's no not real repentance and real
grace here it's a completely contrived
situation and the minute that you show
them a little bit of your neck they're
going to hack your head off okay that's
what this is about you've it's i would
call this
the hank schrader rule and i think
joe rogan would do very well to heed the
hank schrader rule the hank schrader
rule comes from breaking bad it's the
scene where walt's brother-in-law hank
the cop
is killed and the rule is this
do not apologize to the mob do not
grovel to the mob
because the mob made up its mind ten
minutes ago
hank
said to me
you gotta tell me you gotta tell them
now that we can work this out please
please
what
you want me to beg
you're the smartest guy i ever met
and you're too stupid to see
he made up his mind 10 minutes ago
do what you're going to do
that's what happens and and hank was
right and walt was wrong walt's saying
no just apologize just say this will go
away and then we can all go back to
normal you can't go back to normal when
when the cancel mob asks for your
apology
they're not
trying to figure out what to do with you
they've already made up their mind
they're going to kill you
they're going to kill your career all
right their guy i hope they don't kill
you literally but they're certainly
going to kill your they've already made
up their mind
so the question is what are you going to
do now and that's the question for joe
rogan to make and unfortunately
i think spotify
is pushing him in the direction
of censorship there's a report out now
that as of saturday
113 episodes of the joe rogan podcast
have been taken down
rogan reportedly made the decision
himself
but this decision was made after
conversations that he had with spotify
it's very easy to judge joe rogan for
taking down his episodes right now you
say no you're giving in to censorship
you're giving in to cancel culture joe
rogan has a 100 million dollar contract
with spotify
100 million dollar contract and the the
thing about temptation
is that it's tempting that's what makes
it tough
and all of us who have who have given in
to many
less enticing temptations than 100
million dollars
all of us who
you know see a an extra drink at the end
of the night we can't say no or you see
a cute chick at the end of the bar you
can't say no or you see the extra plate
of turkey on thanksgiving you can't say
no
we're judging joe rogan for saying i'd
kind of like to keep the 100 million
dollars thanks
no the tough thing about temptation is
that it is tempting
the question is though what does joe
rogan want what does he want to have
happen now it seems to me the mob
already made up its mind spotify though
they're not firing joe rogan outright
they are appeasing the mob and they're
placing disclaimers on his episodes with
conservatives on the issue of kovid
they're taking down
over a hundred episodes apparently of
his show all the saucy
interesting episodes they're just taking
those down
they're saying that he needs to have way
more democrats they're neutering the
show they are neutering the show they've
already done it
they've already taken down the saucy
spicy stuff that the libs don't like
so then the question for rogan is what
kind of show does he want
i don't know i can't answer that for him
i don't know joe rogan is a comedian he
was a sitcom actor a stand-up comedian
who became
probably the most trusted broadcaster in
america i imagine he didn't expect that
but what kind of show does he want
the establishment is ordering things
such that he can be an insanely rich man
who will work for a very long time
doing a completely innocuous show
that doesn't rock the boat
or
he can be content just having a lot a
lot of money but not an insane but just
a lot a lot a lot of money
in doing the show that he wants to do
what do you want to do i don't know i
hope i hope that at a certain point of
wealth you say screw it i don't care
whatever
this is kind of what chappelle did dave
chappelle did this at comedy central he
was offered a crazy contract i think it
was 50 million dollars but it was to do
a show he didn't want to do he said
stuff it i've got enough money i'm gonna
go do my own thing
what's he gonna do it's going to matter
because
if they can do this to rogan
there is no reason that they should keep
any of the rest of our shows up on
spotify
ben
me
matt walsh
candice oh my gosh candace
any of the certainly any of the daily
why why are you going to keep us up
i i like to think that the reason
they'll keep us up is because they don't
want to just shut out half of the
country
for saying perfectly ordinary common
commonplace things
but if they're even going to go after
rogan who is a liberal
why wouldn't they go after us too
a lot is writing on this decision mr
rogan
i don't know joe rogan personally we
follow each other on twitter but a lot
is writing on this man i know it's tough
but
stand firm come on push back push back
please you gotta ring the bell subscribe
that way you'll get notifications if for
whatever reason you do not get
notifications for our videos head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you